tutti ragazzi quindi minuto che sono
video sono fatti jvc se un suo sandro
fabbro che significa canzone horror in
inglese poi non so in che senso
non fraintendetemi l'ascolto dieci volte
al giorno e canzoni di adel non erano
era per scherzare andiamo sui new game
allora i joystick innanzitutto
prenditori infinera culo perché costa
mano del cazzo vuoi che faccia permesso
ecco l'erede di kakà anche lui ascolta
dell enav è normale ragazzi siamo dice
che quali ascoltami zio chi ti ha dato
il permesso di arredare casa non perché
fai cagare
ma serio proprio a me non importa
ragazzi vado vado avanti ancora non ho
capito il senso di gioco prefiggo cioè
uno i pochi horror che ho fatto in terza
persona io ne sono tutti in prima
persona quindi minchia tanta roba
permesso come cos'è come si entra nelle
porte cioè a così ma a me 4 questa è
casa mia ragazzi che sono entrato in una
casa completamente a caso c'era non
posso rischiare la prossima dai forse
origliare nelle porte ragazzi devo dire
che se sento satana nella dall'altra
parte non vado satana sei tu non c'è
stata non ragazzini possa interesse non
c'è stata né a posto siccome lo ha
rilevato alcuna presenza ostile
stavo per dire questo prokop ci ho
ripensato bene per ora solo manata al
muro cosa tranquilla 4 mi mi ricorda
troppo residenti volta sta roba in terza
persona è bellissimo non voglio che
guardare questa melma hai vinto esatto
zio esatta è esattamente la cosa che
avrei detto io quindi perfetto ci
capiamo rapido nel sito lugar donde che
che parla spagnolo va male zio perché
non parlo spagnolo non capite un cazzo
di quello che hai detto un carra fido
vuol dire veloce io l'unica cosa che so
dire in spagnolo è esaurito e smi bueno
però necessito salsa verde cosa devo
fare perché la porta e tutta nera
ac di tua madre ma [ __ ] che agazzi
in mano si è bloccato tutto ma cosa
console cliccato cosa cos'è perché no e
piazza cosa clicca
a qualcuno qualcuno mi spiega il dr anzi
non lo voglio sapere va bene ok ragazzi
siamo qua mi fatti capire cosa devo fare
e che non ho capito mi dice a rapido
hanno detto ciao scemo
stavolta se ne sbattuto il cazzo non mi
ha detto niente ma meglio così posso
uscire non posso uscire lega niente st
portare daniel non ce l'ha fatta
supporta un kick start up e adesso
adesso mia falsità di qik sto cazzo
rissa control continuano a far niente se
mi fai continuare gli faccio il culo si
apre qualcosa in staccata
ciao una porta che grazie a di che poi
qualcuno mi spiega l'utilità di mettere
due porte attaccate così scaccia
el'architetto lista casa topo gigio che
poi una non si apre l'altra si cela
siete scemi una lettera dedicata ad
usher
ma chi campa antezza leicester
dj gasparin la sento una massa se se mi
spunta qualcosa madonna gli schiaffi
altro che lasciati faccio diventare il
miglior jason derulo non sia per niente
ma se esco dalla porta dalla quale sono
entrato tipo così come la fuga mela
fungo solo un codardo se ne andrebbe
prima di finire la demo che va bene così
così preferisco essere un codardo
guardano i montaggi sua e meno male che
ci sono passato prima in quella porta
sono sti cazzi dove perché c'è la
telecamera così non vedo niente poteva
esserci satana davanti non vedo nulla ho
trovato un panno
ma la fisica del gioco è fatto
abbastanza bene cioè posso fare così
paola norma il panno fantastico bene o
un panno la mia vita è completa posso
uscire grazie veramente non sono una
donna non so se avete preso per una
donna ma le donne vanno in cucina non io
sono fa vj so se avete presente quello
che fa i video i ragazzi non sento mai
un cazzo nelle porte però se mi spunta
qualcuno no vabbè ecco sono in cucina mi
ha preso per donna ragazzi mi ha preso
va bene che non ho la barba lo capisco
che è strano però non vuol dire che che
se non ho la barba devo vivere in cucina
non sono una donna molto io tengo la
porta bloccata ma [ __ ] bloccato
esci e sei bravo
[Musica]
probabilmente ragazzi la mia nonna che
voleva darmi da mangiare perché faceva
più o meno così per non è che ti salva
cristo santo di farti tutto ma come è
possibile già uno muore una volta arriva
alla fine un passo dalla fine muore e
lei rifarsi tutto geniale porca [ __ ]
st porta così strano ma ho trovato bello
del disegno capisco saul ciao saul che
del nome carino che c'hai potrei
chiamarti calogero questa la chiave
soggetto anche dove infilare l'asta
chiave il problema è che non ci arriverò
mai nella vita non si sente niente non
si è sentito se c'è qualcosa mi girano
ok e [ __ ] e il bastone allora che
devo fa spiega mi domanda alle big non
sfonda la porta
mortacci tua grazie questa roba è
bellissima perché voi guardate un core
cioè notate notate la nottata e
l'eleganza e la possenza di questa corsa
molto mascolina cioè una cosa che manco
alex schwarzer che il campione olimpico
di marcia farebbe una roba e cioè sei
veramente un figo bene proprio la gente
ti vuole 6 acclamato dalle folle siamo
ci siamo ci siano corri corri maledetto
lorido vai vai vai vai in un camminare
che c'è qualcuno in casa corrida che col
che cosa da atleta fantastico ho bisogno
di una chiave celo celo cosa vuoi dalla
mia vita no non lo sono entrato
che culo che culo assurdo accendi b per
l'amor di dio che queste luci non fanno
cioè lampeggiano che cos'è queste sono
note e non me ne frega un cazzo dico
sinceramente io basta che me ne vada
doppio se c'è una bibbia non so se in
questo momento mi interessano le
librerie
e sa esattamente quello che intendevo
perfetto quindi grazie rifiuto l'offerta
e vado avanti grazie mille possono
ridare ripensandoci leggiamoci un bel
pezzo della bibbia in questo momento mi
sembra proprio la cosa giusta pago lo
scoppiettio delle luci che c'è in sto
posto possiamo farci tranquillamente una
discoteca rega cielo di covo
tranquillamente si può uscire
no perché c'è quello con le catene che
sta giustamente sarà andato ragazzi
incredibile ma vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai sondato è svendere ma chiunque
fosse perfetto
[ __ ] [ __ ] ero concentrato a
pensare dove dovessi andare più che al
più che al gioco li mortacci sua o cos'è
matchbox andrebbe essere fiammiferi che
posso dare fuoco alla casa carino non
hanno usa li usa di che tanto da dar
fuoco a tutto cioè ma si ammazzi anche
uno stronzo me ne frega niente che dai
fuoco alla casa fa niente quindi il
nemico che sto affrontando la e l'ombra
di una persona che non esiste rapido
necessito di un lugar donde nascondermi
devo trovare un luogo in cui nascondermi
ok rapido rapido rapido rapido rapido
rapido non mi può trovare qui zero cioè
sono spiazzato totale sotto tavolo ma
mica che esco di qua mi trova nessuno
mai nella vita cioè la luce puntata in
faccia bruttissima mai sono così davanti
a tutti c'è il livello di chiunque mi
vede sono più visibile così che
normalmente oddio se n'è andato se serio
non posso tipo combinarle le cose bene
ho dato fuoco alla cabina è adesso la
mia vita è completa c'è un finito gioco
ragazzi cos'è qual è il senso che se
messa video da fuoco al camino
spiegatemelo conca ragazzi abbiamo
appurato che abbiamo appurato che sto
giocare a merda questo abbiamo appurato
sicuramente ragazzi l'ultima porta
quindi ma da controllare questa solo che
possa accendere la luce prima a luce
grazie bedi che io con la luce a ragazzi
sfatiamo ai miti con la luce non
appaiono i mostri se voi accendete la
luce dina che solo le 4 di notte tutti
vanno i mostri vanno via questa cosa
funziona quindi ma convinto sì
capraia e cascate e venne allora
fisicamente com'è possibile si sono
attaccate le caccole a che schifo è
comunque più horror del gioco lo stesso
quindi perfetto paolo ragazzi qualcuno
che l'episodio è stato allora
ricordatevi una cosa le luci servono per
scacciare i mostri cazzata se mi
vogliono mangiare vivi di notte anche
con la luce accesa
c'avete nel culo
peccato ragazzi di un colore episodio è
stato figo ma veramente figo perché 33
un indie ma è fatto veramente bene per
essere uniti solo che si muore
tanto si muore tanto e non si capisce
una mazza però dettagli che ragazzi se
vi è piaciuto ma senza un certo momento
è un mi piace anche a faccia di facebook
e con il video tratta descrizione se non
sono vestiti sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video come al solito bella
ragazzi